as we showed you last month deep-sea
explorers found the USS Hornet in the
South Pacific earlier this year the
world war ii aircraft carrier was lost
in battle in 1942 mark phillips was on
board the research ship when the robot
submarines discovered the wreck three
and a half miles below the ocean's
surface
now we're learning the USS Hornet was
not the only ship located on that
expedition mark is in London with the
newest update for American naval history
books mark good morning
good morning well you know what they say
about busses that you wait and you wait
for one and then to come along at the
same time try that with aircraft
carriers to be able to see the
instruments here we're two and a half
miles down peering inside the cockpit of
an avenger torpedo bomber from the
sunken World War two aircraft carrier
USS Wasp two seats look the plane is not
just a relic it's a clue where it lies
can the wasp itself be far away the wasp
had been part of the ferocious 1942 air
and sea battle for the strategic subs
Pacific island of Guadalcanal and all of
our sudden we got hit with torpedoes Jim
Forrester 98 now 21 years old on the
wasp that day
imagine yourself lifted right up out of
your chair right now and you had nothing
to do with it up you go that's what
happened one of the torpedoes that hit
the fuel tanks the ship was an inferno
176 of her crew were dead the rest
ordered to abandon ship
grab meadows and the family jewels and
and jumped into the into the Pacific yes
the wasp has been lost for almost 77
years but the deep water research vessel
petrol has been combing the Pacific
looking for long lost war wrecks
we recently watched mission leader Rob
craft and his crew find another carrier
the USS Hornet this is everything this
is Hornet this
I saw where they had found the Hornet
and I said we'll take a look over on the
other side and you'll find the watch
shall we it's almost like the searchers
were listening all righty
three two one splash we can now report
the petrol crew have found the wasp on
the other side of Guadalcanal more or
less where Jim Forrester said it was she
was a mere two and a half miles down so
a mile less deep than Hornet
but the wasp was actually harder to find
because the research on where she sank
was less clear they say you got to be
good to be lucky but were you more lucky
or more good you know we did our best in
analyzing the data coming up with the
best possible sinking location for her
and it turned out to be accurate luck
skill or a little of each we show Jim
Forrester what they found to him it was
more than an old wreck it was home to me
more than just a ship this was home to
you for two and a half years or so
enough yeah of course we're looking at
more than just a wreck there we're
looking at a war grave as well yeah I
lost two real good friends they were a
be Asian Ordinance Minh and they
probably were down in the magazines
where the bombs were stored where they
didn't stand a chance
the ultimate satisfaction is you get to
see the humanity side of it and you know
bringing history to life it starts as a
technical exercise absolutely and then
becomes about people yeah Jim Forrester
went on to a remarkable 30-year Navy
career rising from enlisted man to navy
commander it sounds to me like you've
been a pretty lucky guy all your life
starting back that day on the on the
wasp well it was wasps that did it for
me and now she's been found the late
Navy's latest memorial and war grave and
a protected one the exact location of
these wrecks is kept secret by the Navy
and the people who find her just because
they're trying to keep scavenge
years away Deanna Wow mark thank you and
how much do we love Jim Forrester right
now it's 98 years I don't but he still
has a vivid recollection yep
nicely done mark though he's got tons of
stories to tell